front page The Wall Street Journal blast
at Gaza Hospital kills hundreds hundreds
oh geez what really happened uhoh the
Wall Street Journal posted this one at
6:58 p.m. tonight us experts say
evidence suggests Palestinian rocket hit
Gaza Hospital suggests oh suggest hit
the hospital hit the hospital okay
ladies and gentlemen how about this
article from Tim cast was published well
before the Wall Street Journal who
apparently just does not want to admit
they were wrong on the front page
because here's the damage it appears to
be the parking lot Oliver Alexander said
IDF Drone footage from the hospital from
after the attack shows damage that is
more consistent with a failed rocket
than a jdam majority of the damage is
concentrated on the car park with no
visible crater we also have uh this
photo right here daylight I mean it's
it's bad okay you know I'm people got
injured in this these cars on fire no
crater the hospital was not leveled it
appears
no hundreds of civilians did not die
they lied they lied this is going to be
the first in a long oh yeah long line of
these conflicts it's it's going to be
opportunistic on both sides everybody's
going to be foaming at the mouth
chomping at the bit to take advantage of
any and every little thing that they can
what they what we had we had a super
chat last night and someone said a Hamas
rocket could not level a a building it
had to have been from Israel and I I
immediately said was the hospital
leveled I don't is that is that what
happened the whole hospital just
collapsed leveled leveled see we go from
struck to leveled yep and the what they
were what they were claiming was that
the whole hospital was hit and collapsed
killing hundreds of people that was the
argument they that would be awful and
thankfully that didn't happen and we
should we should and so I mean this is
this is our fault too I mean we're
debating whether or not whether or not
it was Israel or Palestine and we never
stopped to ask whether it really
happened or not it's really difficult to
figure it out just like we were looking
at that image of Rashida T earlier
wearing the Q and on Shaman hat trying
to figure out is it a deep fake or not
and and it's fake but things things make
it out into the internet really quickly
and everybody has an agenda that they're
trying to push I mean theend the
internet's the biggest game of telephone
of all time the agenda I want to push is
that the United States should stay out
of it financially yeah I do too yeah I I
at this point especially but the but now
Biden wants to give him $100 million so
just justifying the terror attack the
Biden Administration is trying to make
both sides happy and they will proceed
to let everyone down because they also
issu they're like we are issuing SS
against several members and entities
affiliated with Hamas so they are trying
to cover all their bases this is not
going to work the only option really
would be to not get involved but of
course they're just making us more
involved in ways that are so complicated
and are obviously going to backfire
Biden's going to strengthen his Base by
pumping money into any cause he can
related to helping Palestine and leftist
activists meanwhile conservatives in the
United States are going to scream for
Israel and to dump more of the United
States dollars into Israel we all
already give them billions of dollars we
should just stop giving everyone money
we just thoughts and prayers like we're
not the world's ATM we the reason we
give them money is so they spend it
that's it yeah we want you you give $100
million to a handful of world leaders
they will live like kings and spend that
meaning we will do the labor on their
behalf cuz what do you get what what do
you buy with US Dollars things from
people who take US dollars for the most
part as American citizens but then it
circulates in their countries or that
that wealth that we produce is shifted
off to their country these world leaders
then agree to use the Petro dollar and
this is the game that's being played yep
not everywhere though some not
everywhere yep some people are saying
they've had enough and I don't know
whether that's going to play out yep I
don't know if that's going to be good or
bad for us but it is happening isn't
isn't it kind of funny that around the
same time the bricks nations are
announcing their own currency and
several nations are announcing they're
going to stop trading in US dollars or
they're going to start trading in
Juan World War II seems to be breaking
out yep how convenient we we've got
19,000 Personnel in the Mediterranean
just outside of of Israel we've got
2,000 uh more ready to be deployed Yep
they're saying the Pentagon is PR
preparing them to go on the ground
potentially yeah I I I I look the
embassy in theit the US Embassy in
Lebanon has set on fire last night yeah
so sad they need they need to cast his
belly so like okay so you're saying that
like uh supporting Hamas will strengthen
his base what is the size of assuming
got 81 million votes right what's the
size of his base and do we really is is
it really believable like is that mostly
people supporting Palestine he's Biden's
going to lose from this I mean I don't
think it's a good it doesn't it doesn't
make sense to me like I I have a lot of
friends who are they they political
they're they're they're Democrats
whatever fine but they're not they're
not here supporting H right now well
hold not everyone who's Pro Palestine is
pro Hamas it's they're two different
things they're related but I think that
you I would hope that a lot of people
who are wanting USA to go and support
Palestinians who are suffering they
don't want to support terrorists even if
I disagree with them I don't I don't
think that they necessarily want to see
terrorism supported but look the reality
is that part of Biden's base are the
same class of people who donate to
institutions like Harvard and we are
seeing that those donors are pulling
their dollars he's hurting either way
there's no no positive move him well
it's not a good move I understand the
argument that Palestine is not Hamas but
I do kind of think that's a bit naive
because if you're if if Joe Biden says
I'm going to give $100 million to the
people of Palestine we know where that
money is really going it's going to get
confiscated by Hamas confiscated or just
given to them they're the government in
Gaza they will just take it and it's
also basically saying if you engage in
ter even if the money was was
specifically given to Nos and it
resulted in people getting cleaner water
and buildings and air conditioning and
and other things they they need then
Hamas is basically told like well
whenever you need money whenever you
want money for your people whether it
goes to you or not all you got to do is
go kill thousands of isra terrible
absolutely and and so when it comes to
these people who are like we we we
defending Palestine it's okay well the
Palestinian people vote for vote for
Hamas not all of them though no but but
the point is there there that you you
can argue for civilians that I totally
get but the government stands in the way
and what is the solution then the
solution is the United States has got to
stay out of it I completely agree so but
people who say I'm that want to support
Palestine no there's no way to support
one get creative haven't figured out how
to do that no no we can we can stop
supporting uh all of it altogether or
you can support all of it like the idea
that you can support the Palestinian
people and not be supporting Hamas is
incorrect I know I'm not saying you are
directly funding and allowing Hamas to
engage in what they're doing but what
you give when you donate to these groups
will find its way to empowering Hamas
former Congressman Justin Amash uh his
family was Palestinian Palestinian
Christians and they were sponsored over
here by Christian missionaries so I
don't know how easier challenging that
is currently but that's one way to try
to help people is get them out of that
situation people who are trying to leave
that I that I can that's what the first
minister of Scotland is saying today he
said Scotland will take refugees from be
careful who you invite into your country
and home that's it I mean when you've
got I think the latest numbers that we
pulled up a couple days ago was like uh
Hamas won the election with like 44% or
something I don't I'm I'm not an expert
in the region but 44% is I mean that's
that's like the margins we get for
presidents in this country I don't I'm
not going to blame everybody Jo Biden
the people who voted for Jo Biden are to
blame but you you you you
have it's Inseparable right there there
is going to be in any material support
to Gaza material support going towards
Hamas sure it's just like Live Aid when
they when politicians and celebrities
and musicians everybody got together to
to pump money into Africa it went to
African Warlords it didn't go to the
people who needed it this is true for
for anywhere we give money this includes
Israel yeah absolutely when we when we
when we give money and donate to Israel
you are strengthening the economy and
the structure and the infrastructure of
Israel which ultimately can run up to
the IDF to the Israeli government I am
not saying that is right or wrong for
either I'm saying they're Inseparable so
that there's I'm frustrated by the
people who are like we don't we don't
like what Hamas is doing we support the
Palestinian people and it's like well
the plurality of the voters support
Hamas and Hamas just massacred a bunch
of civilians and now our government's
giving them more money I got a simple
solution cut it off I think no no more
no more fun the best thing that we could
do is try to try to facilitate peace
talks it's not gone well in the past
that's that's about it that's and that's
and that's the thing it's like I look
man there's no easy answer here yeah I
see what what I see here with this
conflict is really exemplified by what
we see with the left
where these leftists are cheering for
death a lot of them are yeah I mean when
they post a picture of a paraglider it's
gross they're celebrating death
absolutely no question and maybe there's
the banality of evil in the morons on
the left who have no idea what actually
happened and are just waving the flags
and raising the fist but when these
groups organize an outright issue
statement saying they're Freedom
Fighters when the professor said the
professor said settlers are not
civilians they will lie to your face as
they've done they will cheer for death
and then we're supposed to sit back and
be like let's be reasonable here guys
let's make sure we're helping the
civilians like no no no dude dude
they're lying to you and they're
committing the people Hamas is killing
people I'm not saying Israel is innocent
I'm not saying any country in war there
there's there's there's always some some
Nuance in the conflict there's always
collateral damage it's it's never good
but I'm just sick of being lied to and
when you look at what the left says and
does they cheer for your death and they
lie about being victims so it's just
like stop just stop the Israeli
government does not treat people well
over there but there's no that doesn't
justify murdering people with
paragliders and it's really unfortunate
that people on both sides no one will
just admit murder is wrong so so uh when
when we have this video that comes out
um and we had this we had Max blumthal
and he's talking about the march of
return okay Palestinians peacefully
March to the fence with their hands up
and Israel still shot at them okay that
that's the kind of story we're like oh
wow I mean like that that sounds really
bad why would they do that well here's
the question I have I'll ask you as I
ask anybody if Israel removed all of the
security perimeter around Gaza and told
the people of Gaza they're free to move
through Israel what would
happen oh wow I mean you'd see a lot of
different mixed reactions there but I
think you'd see VI
Massac by who I mean both sides I assume
I doubt the the old ladies and the kutes
are going to pick up guns and go charge
not old ladies no what likely would
happen is there's going to be a bunch of
fighting age young men mainly Hamas
substantially more than we saw actually
paraglide because paragliding is
difficult and more expensive and they
would Rampage through the kutzas The
Villages make their way to Tel Aviv and
start just massacring people with rifles
I think you'd probably see some Israelis
who were angry doing similar things yes
but the Israelis aren't going to storm
into Gaza if the if the security barrier
of Gaza was removed Israeli citizens are
not going to run full speed into Gaza to
start massacring people yeah it's
defensive versus offensive I think
they're missing that I mean so there was
this Irish politician who I saw a clip
of talking about how I think his name is
Paul Murphy talking about how people
should he he's Pro Palestine or I mean
you could I don't know if you would
argue that he's Pro Hamas but he's
saying that this is not a conflict
between equals because uh Israel is
significantly more financially and
militarily advant but I don't
think that may be true on the other hand
the solution being like we should have
peace talks is almost to me INE
ineffective because there's no peace
between these two people they been at
will they have been at Conflict for a
long time and Israel has been you know
has taken aggressive moves in in their
own steps and Palestine and Hamas have
responded in turn I mean what would
peace possibly look like between these
two I don't think that Hamas rejects I
think the best you can never back I mean
I I don't think that there's any from
what I know and I've been trying to
research this more for for Palestinians
there is no compromise because they
always feel like they are getting the
short on sick the best you could do is
try to negotiate a two-state solution I
don't think that there will ever be
peace in the Middle East but I think
that it's possible we could deescalate
this and there would be less death there
will never be a two-state solution when
one side says no and from The River To
The Sea well both sides are saying no
right now yeah but one side says from
The River To The Sea like the left that
stormed that Capital they're they're
chanting for the eradication of Israel
Patrice cullers of BLM 2015 said and
Israel outright so if we're going to
Israel and saying like what can we do to
stabilize the region with a two-state
solution Israel has an open door for
negotiation I'm not saying they're
innocent didn't a lot of people in Hamas
didn't they didn't they write in their
Charter that they wanted to go back to
like 1967 agreement and have a two-state
solution so so the issue I want to be
arguing for Hamas it feels gross yeah no
I mean hamas's original charter said the
eradication of Israel and and I I think
it might have specifically referred to
the Jews themselves right and then it
was amended I think in 2017 to tone that
language down probably because they knew
they relied on International support but
those people's sentiments don't change
the the issue is I don't care who you
support the issue is there are two
ideologically opposed groups yeah there
is one chanting from The River To The
Sea okay like the other one's just
saying just saying it quietly maybe
Israel I I I I don't know if there is a
slogan of Israel to chant other than
we've seen some people say they want to
Glass Gaza or something like that that's
quite intense I don't know if the
government is outright coming out and
saying those things it seems to be the
the the Israeli government understands
the nuances of international relations
and is trying at the very least we can
say this whether they are or not they're
putting on the front of we try to
minimize civilian casualties and we are
only responding we are not
instigating so when you have war between
two factions and one side wins there is
no solution where you're just like well
no I I understand these are Waring fact
action with deep ideological tensions
going back thousands of years but let's
just let's just have peace it's like
well certainly not that's very naive
it's it's never going to happen that's
very naive I I just I'm looking at this
and I'm like well Hamas just lied about
everything I mean they they paraglides
into uh into Israel and they started
killing civilians killing children and
that is their their their mil their
their their uh military Doctrine kill
civilians and capture civilians is part
terrible so how do we have peace with
that we don't have peace with Hamas but
we but Hamas is so intrin the rest the
rest of the people in Palestine I feel
would really love to have peace talks be
a thing I I think I think that's not
true I think that's then then the the
answer would be for Israel to invade
Gaza and excise Hamas and then restore
Democratic institutions to the reigning
individuals guess what they will not
accept that the other Arabic Nations
have outright threatened that if Israel
does that it's going to escalate so
that's not going to happen and then
Israel's other answer is air strikes on
Hamas targets which results in massive
collateral damage so we're stuck with an
open air stop funding any of it you
should not be involved in an unsolvable
problem the the one who and then another
group that loses is the American people
as more of our tax money is funded into
I think we should absolutely I think one
of the ways that you might see a better
outcome in this is if we stopped giving
Israel United States money here's the
the argument Ben airo made which is not
without its Merit I don't completely
agree is that Israel will not allow
itself to cease to exist it will not
allow defeat and it and it is considered
what the fourth strongest military it is
also widely speculated they have nuclear
weapons yeah the Samson option is if
Israel is facing extermination they will
use nukes to defend themselves okay if
the US does not make every attempt to
stabilize the conflict it will devolve
into World War III that's basically what
Ben Shapiro's argument was if Israel inv
invades Gaza now and then Iran responds
Syria and Lebanon respond and then
Israel gets overwhelmed from external
forces without us support Israel fires a
nuke on Iran Iran retaliates the region
lights up pulling in a bunch of
different nations leading to a WID scale
if if at the very least a regional
Annihilation worst case World War II so
it's up to Team America World Police to
step in that's the argument from tell
everyone my argument is the US interv
itself exacerbates that in the exact
same way absolutely and there is no
solution other than we walking full
speed as fast as we can into World War
II I don't think there's going to be
ever like a a literal peace in the
Middle East I think we could see maybe
less conflict and I would love for them
to give that a try and removing our
money is the first step in that there is
one path towards
peace well there's actually two the the
the the path towards peace that we hope
for is generational uh um
proximity leading to a generational
deescalation yep as more and more of
these people grow up in these areas and
want nothing to do with the conflict and
just to live better lives and the old
ideas and traditions Fade Away they'll
start to say like why why why were my
great- grandparents fighting you like I
I don't want to have anything to do with
that man just please leave me alone so
one of the things that helps uh uh
helped racism kind of dissipate in the
United States was proximity people
growing up next to people of other races
being like we are friends like they said
about that guy was not true and so it
removes those stigmas and stereotypes we
could also remove sanctions on Iran and
kind of just leave the rest of the
Middle East alone and stop engaging in
regime change every now and then that
would probably help I don't think that's
going to i i i that that won't stabilize
the region I think I think it would stop
destabilizing it so much I I I think
before the United States was in
Afghanistan you had the Soviets there in
the and and and then we we back the muad
de because we're it's a proxy war so
whether it's us China or Russia there is
going to be foreign influence
manipulating and you and and and
fighting over the Middle East I'm not
saying I have a good solution I'm just
saying that it seems that we are facing
with with thousands of years of
ideological hatred there the two
solutions would be can we just do
everything in our power to try and
stabilize this so that over a long
period of time the fighting calms down
maybe not especially when you see the
the the children in gazar being taught
explicitly to hate they hate us hate
hate us and
the other solution is the one that
nobody likes to admit but is in all
sci-fi the Trope of what the AI does to
bring about peace wipe out humans well I
mean that seems a little maybe a bit
much that's the extreme instance yeah
there's peace when there's no one left
yeah I think I think we could not do
that I I think you know that our inv the
goal is to avoid that from happening and
that is the the the terrifying outcome
of if we can't solve the problem in
involvement in the in the Middle East
has just been an absolute failure since
the Iraq War since Desert Storm really
well before that I mean since since the
muhad well I mean going I mean look Iran
sure the Irani Revolution yeah
absolutely and even the idea of
proximity doesn't necessarily bear
itself out to work because we may have
had that at a certain period of time but
then the kids go to college and they
learn all the things that they learn now
which teach you to hate your neighbor
rather than to actually learn to
understand them so I don't know as long
as information is freely passed from
generation to generation if that is
something that's going to happen it's
going to take an excessively long period
of time and as long as military action
is still happening in the interim you
create new enemies with every new
military action students here hate the
Second Amendment in guns so you know
that's not that's not well I don't know
about woke the far left likes guns yeah
it's the liberals who don't the Liberals
don't uh yeah the left loves gun left is
college students here I would say they
don't like guns it is also funny that
you mention I don't know about that you
think they like guns yeah leftists like
guns they have they have like the Red
Guard they have the social they have the
John Brown Gun Club but I think leftist
college students are unique partially
because of the impact that the Parkland
school shooting had that was like one of
the big high school to
college I don't think
so vos's pro gun all of the high
schoolers that I worked with who are now
in college prominent leftist with
hundreds of thousands of followers and
he's 26 he's a he's a small demog he
represents a small demographic of
gun-loving leftists I I think you're
wrong the left the leftists love guns
it's the Liber it's the average liberal
that hates the guns now there there's
far less there's far less of your gun
owning Blue Dog Democrats than there was
before yes and the rest have been turned
by the media by Hollywood by all these
places to be extremely anti-gun because
they read articles every day that says
there's been 90 school shootings today
um and all these things it is funny that
you mentioned Team America World Police
because that movie you know I I mean
actually when you think about the people
that made it back there might have been
more libertarian but it would have been
Hollywood
back in the day that would have been
very like uh America needs to stop
intervening in these foreign conf maybe
we'll get another one you know except
this time it seems more like instead of
just stay out it's just give everybody
money you know so which is never going
to work that's the most ridiculous
solution of all time Team America World
Bank thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 pm
and become a member over at
timcast.net shows exclusive thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time